hi all uh my name is Vincent and I'll be
your host for the next four talks and
now the thought is
titled replacing proprietary SAS with
open source building marketing analytics
web app for python
and this talk represents a case study of
replacing a proprietary marketing
analytics platform with a dashboard and
web app creating
ecosystem by
Leo NTS Leo is the co-founder and CEO of
datapain and open source framework for
creating data apps using Python and
jupyter this one welcome here
[Applause]
um yeah my name is Leo I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Dex paint and in this talk
I'm going to show you how we can use
data menu alongside other open source
libraries to replace external SAS
platforms so in this case a marketing
analytics platform
um first a little bit about data pen
so data painting is an open source of
SDK for building internal data products
using python we're going to show you a
really quick example of the sort of
things people build to
continue
um
what you can use database to do is
create reports dashboards and
interactive apps programmatically from
inside python so this is a report that
someone created to do some kind of
machine learning analysis
see that I've got a couple Pages here
and inside of this are a bunch of data
Bank components such as tabs alongside
visualizations from Python and data sets
so this is a totally Standalone report
it actually doesn't even require a
server to run you can export it as a
HTML file email it to someone send it on
slack but at the same time data Sprint
also allows you to create full data
products so that ranges from automated
dashboards again 100 using python all
the way to web apps that also run
backend python code so I'm going to
combine all of those different things to
see if we can replace a proprietary
software as a service
so just give it back
here
um
you can check us out give us a star look
at the gallery
so
hopefully this isn't a controversial
statement
um at this at this conference but we
believe python is the best way to
analyze data and I think it should be
obvious from looking at all the other
talks that you're seeing today I think
that the way to think about this is that
the rate of change that you get in open
source and that you're going to python
is just so radically different to when
you're using an off-the-shelf
proprietary tool python that's probably
the richest ecosystem for analyzing data
in the world and we obviously big fans
of using it from everything from you
know machine learning sophisticated
stuff but also simple Analytics
the problem is that most of these things
are inaccessible to 99 of people right
most people cannot run python if you
take a Jupiter notebook or a python
script and you send it to someone who is
not technical they're not going to be
able to make use of it
stakeholders don't necessarily want to
see all of your code where you're like
dropping a man or teaming up some data
they're more focused on the end result
a lot of analysts and people in
traditional analytics teams no SQL and
user API installed like Tableau or
looker and don't like Python and I think
it's fair to say that packaging and
running python is oftentimes a challenge
I don't think you want to sit down with
your head of marketing and help them
create a virtual environment and debug
installing my arrow and getting a bunch
of constraint problems so python is not
an easy thing actually to get in the
hands of people who are not Tangled
so what do they do
usually they will go and buy a
third-party product that is not created
using the open source ecosystem so
I'm going to use the example of a
marketing app that pulls data from
Shopify does some simple analyzes but
they're actually boatloads of these
vanities who create solutions for a
specific use case which realistically
you could probably do in 50 to 100 lines
of python if you knew how to but they
can't do it because python is not
accessible to them they can't take a
python script or a notebook and run it
and so what's the problem
what's wrong with this
um I think that there are good sides I
think there's benefits a lot of these
Solutions they're very accessible
they integrate heavily with the tools
these people use so they know how to get
the data in the right shape and they
also integrate with where these people
want data surfaced so maybe they want it
inside of slack or teams maybe they want
it inside of something like Salesforce
or tablet so there are definite benefits
and I think for companies who don't have
anyone who can write code these
platforms can be a really really good
choice
I think the downside is the a they're
expensive so you can end up paying you
know two to three hundred thousand
dollars a year for something that you
can maybe do and 50 or 100 likes python
um and they make it very difficult to
integrate with data sets that are not
inside of their constraints they're
generally extremely inflexible both on
the data side but also on the analysis
side so say you wanted to integrate with
another data source like your Warehouse
or more common than not what we see is
something like 2003 error Excel file
that holds the entire business logic of
the company that gets emailed around
they make it very difficult they're very
much a um everyone gets the same thing
right they're not customized to the data
the integration or the analysis that
that company needs
and the other problem is that as we're
seeing through all the talks today
the rate of change in the python
ecosystem is really incredible if you
look at some of the talks you're going
to see
um over the over the conference it's
impossible that these methods are going
to be implemented in a third-party
platform
usually you'll get a small subset of
them a couple of years later but again
you don't get it to ride the wave of all
the cool things you can do using open
source
so what about data apps obviously there
are some great data act Frameworks one
of them is data paint apps they're
obviously platforms like streamlit or
voila
and I think these are fantastic for
helping a data scientist share their
analysis if you want to go from a python
script to something that you want to
throw up maybe demo create a zoom call
their their perfect for for building
that front end but they don't actually
provide an architecture for replacing a
third-party platform so they don't
provide all of those moving pieces for
creating a date product oftentimes they
get used like the report I showed you as
a little bit more like PowerPoint for
data scientists
and that's really because a data product
is a superset of a data app the web
framework is actually a relatively small
part of what a lot a lot of these
platforms do you've obviously got the my
back but you've probably got reporting
as well you need scheduled reporting
background tasks
um maybe dashboards you have a data
integration layer that needs to pull
data from the various platforms that the
um the app needs so that could be an
internal warehouse but that could also
be Shopify in this case you need a way
somewhere to store that so some kind of
O Level there and then you need
integration of automation into the
different platforms that people are
using to actually consume these insights
so data apps are fantastic at what they
do which is building a web server but
they don't give you an end-to-end data
product
so what this usually means to companies
is that you've got the data scientist
writing the couple hundred lines of code
you've maybe got some data Engineers
helping with integration but then
they've got to get a huge number of
other people involved to deliver an
internal products you've got a front-end
engineer probably writing react or view
you've got Central it you then need to
procure like a data warehouse for you to
integrate your data into you've got
back-end teams writing Django or flask
and sooner rather than later you're
basically delivering like an entire
software project which is very expensive
and time consuming so through this land
it makes sense that people go to things
that are not DIY that are not created
using Python and open source and instead
something off the shelf that they can
spend a lot of money on but that they
don't have to get all of these people
inside their company together to deliver
so with this in mind we wanted to find
out if there are a set of new
technologies out there that can change
this
so is there a way to reduce the effort
to deliver a full data product
which changes the dynamic of build
versus buy so it changes whether it
makes sense for people to use Python and
use open source inside their companies
as opposed to going to an external
vendor
and if there are
what is the best in class step for this
so what is the right stack for creating
a data product inside of your company
so the example we're going to use as a
popular marketing analytics product and
this pulls data from Shopify analyzes it
using some common methods such as Coral
analysis retention analytics and Market
Basket analysis and the question we're
trying to answer is can we replace this
using python
so I'm actually going to do the demo
backwards by showing you the finished
products and we'll break that down into
how we actually build that
so here is the application you can see
my design skills are fantastic you've
got a nice image there and what this
allows you to do is select a date range
um of
data from Shopify
so this is all the data as well as
customer data and three different data
sets actually that's merging together
and what it creates here is an
interactive application that I can then
use so I've got my orders some high
level kpis
seems like there's Shopify store is
doing very well
over a billion dollars of Revenue
and I've also got an interactive map
here so this shows the top products
distributed
um over over a geography I've created
this using phone
this also shows me some interesting
summary statistics and some graph that
for instance the average order value the
most commonly
ordered products by day that kind of
thing and you can see that none of this
is really rocket science so doing this
in Python using best-in-class libraries
is not
a research level project actually what a
lot of these platforms do can really be
replaced in a minimum amount of places
the next thing that I've got here is a
Market Basket analysis so this shows
what popular
products are ordered together it sounds
like
round shipping Insurance should probably
be dropped from this to have a very
useful show but shows you what products
are frequently put in the basket at the
same time we have retention analysis if
you've used a traditional analytics
product like mid panel you've probably
looked at a lot of these charts it shows
how many people after ordering will come
back and order something again and we've
got a
a charter here showing which days that
has the most frequent on and then
finally we've just got the entire case
there we've got about a million cells
here that we can load into a contract
the date stable and then say we wanted
to run some sequel on this however we
can actually query that inside of our
app
great so if we go back to the
slides there
earlier we talked about what are the
different parts of this app so obviously
the web app that I just showed you is
one part of that but what are the
different moving pieces that we need to
take into account and for these moving
pieces
what are the best in class libraries
which we can use to get the job done as
easily as possible now one thing to note
here is that we've opted for solutions
that are simple for users to get started
with as opposed to the most powerful so
the goal is not to provide a huge
Enterprise architecture the goal is to
provide a simple way for a regular
company to ship the data product and I'm
going to step through each of these each
of these
parts of the life cycle
so Step One is extracting loading and
transforming the data from the first
place and I think the first question is
why do you need to do this so could we
not just have our app when I click that
run button pull data down from something
like Shopify integrate it and transform
it in process
and the answer is that it's too slow
so even with caching this is very
inefficient and it can take minutes or
hours to join the data from various rest
apis and get it in in the right shape so
it has to happen out of Band of the UI
this is something that like many tasks
in building one of these web products
should not happen when the user is using
the interface this should happen outside
of that
so how do we get the data from Shopify
now luckily python is greater
integration and you can whack up a
python script to pull data from many
platforms that have an API
but you actually don't need to
um there are libraries out there that
make it really easy to take data from
one place and shove it in database so
we're using singer and meltano which
give you connectors to connect to I
think you know hundreds of different
platforms that you can connect into from
Salesforce to Shopify to work day and
then you can load that into a database
or a CSV or wherever you want to use as
your data storage map
so then the question is where should we
store this data should we go to Central
it and say I need a data warehouse
should we get a database deployed and
our answer for this is actually no
you can skip the warehouse and there are
some fantastic libraries which I'm going
to focus here on Duck DB that you can
think of it as giving you a mini data
warehouse that you can spin up in Python
in a few minutes milliseconds so as
opposed to having to build a procure
entire data warehouse you can get an
olap layer for doing a lot of the
analysis and transformation very very
quickly and the obvious question for
this is is it going to be powerful
enough
am I going to be able to do everything I
need to do in a in-memory database in
the answer for most of these answers yes
is that you don't need to do a bunch of
warehousing
um the data is a lot is small enough to
fit in memory and on a single node
with enough um with enough RAM
on air and CPU you can do a lot on
um using libraries like wdb as opposed
to using a
so I definitely check that out if you're
if you're if you're going down that path
the next question is how do you want to
transform and join that data so say
you're pulling data from three different
sources and you want to integrate it
together into a data set for your app
what's the best way to do that
this is often a case of picture poison
if you want to do it in SQL you can do
it in SQL using something on top of a
database like Doc we like to do it uh in
Python we traditionally have been using
Poland and also pandas B2 which is
extremely fast at doing a lot of this
transformation I think there's almost 10
times faster some of the things we're
doing so we're very python versed in the
way that we're doing
finally this can't be map so you don't
want it that someone has to go and hit
run to get the new data integrated so
you also need something to run on the
schedule you will need a chrome job or
something similar which takes the
task that you've created in Python and
executes them maybe every day or every
hour or whatever it is
and you can see here we're using the
Shopify tap from singer IO and then
we're loading that directly into Doug TV
so once we schedule that that takes care
of most of the extraction I'm loading
the data for our
the next layer is building the apps
reports and dashboards on top of this
data so we're using date paint for this
and data pen allows you to
programmatically create everything from
a report
to a scheduled like dashboard to a
full-blown web app programmatically in
Python so in addition to actually the
web app that I ran through here we also
created a report
and this report is special because the
like the one I showed you earlier you
can download it
you can open that and you can see this
is just an HTML file my local machine I
could send this on slack I could send
this in teams I could even embed it into
something like below if I wanted so it's
a way to create things that are most
like the equivalent of a PDF but still
with some of that interactive
um interactive nature and you don't have
to prove yeah which is always
okay
now for the core analysis I think I ran
through most of the libraries that we're
using we're using really quite
off-the-shelf stuff so pandas polars
High arrow for some of the data storage
for this use case there are also really
great domain specific libraries that I'd
encourage you to look at as well so
Shopify in particular has open source
and great python libraries for doing
things like LTV analysis or survival
analysis some of them are using more
classic statistical methods as opposed
to having machine learning so I'm sure
if that's state of the art but we get
really good results with them as well on
the visualization side you can use
whatever visualization might be you want
to
with big uses of Ulta which is beta
light fur I think it fits really well
for creating reusable visualizations
that are lightweight and also
interactive
um but you can use anything from MacBook
liver properly uh the choice systems
Now One Challenge here is that similar
to the data integration side a lot of
this can't happen in the UI so you don't
want it so when someone goes to your app
it's necessarily doing all of the
processing that has to happen before
they can look at it and data pain is a
little different from other Frameworks
and you can actually pre-render a lot of
the views so if I go to that app there
and I'm clicking on a different tab
that's not actually going back to the
server that's all pre-rendered in the
front end and this can happen again out
of Band of someone using your product
you can have a scheduled task that does
obviously the LTD generates the plots
whatever whatever you want to do
now the next the next part of this is
Automation and surfacing so you can
build a fantastic data product that does
everything that people want and no one
will use it because it doesn't integrate
into the platforms where they probably
live
um so an important part we've found of
successfully building an internal data
product is integrating very deeply with
where people already are uh in our
experience that tradition units like
slack or teams so maybe you can have
some kind of triggered tasks that for
instance when a certain metric changes
it sends a report to someone through
slack or through teams the other thing
we found surprisingly is that embedding
inside of Tableau Works quite well so
Tableau is quite extensible and you can
create reports and apps and dashboards
in Python and then we have an extension
so you can embed that into a dashboard
that hopefully someone's already looking
at
so I wouldn't take it for granted that
just building the data product is enough
it really has to fit into somebody's
workflow to make an impact
I'm going to quickly walk through the
code that we built this I've just got
this opening GitHub web editor
I've started using this pen for the full
stop I'm going to get my agreement
that's okay
fantastic
um so you can see here that the stock
analytics.pi I've got about 300 lines of
code and this is just using basically
pandas and alter to do the
visualizations none of it is rocket
science
um this is when I get harboring post you
can you can have a look at it but um
again it's pretty simple stuff on the
actual python side
the second file to look at now is our
app itself
so what these functions do is they
create data pane components you can
think of data paint a little bit like
something like react where you can
create components and you can actually
compose them together so these are the
big numbers that you see in the app and
I can get these and return them from a
function and then connect them together
with some other um some other components
to create both my report and my app so
everything is happening on the actual
app side in these two files here these
are mostly just called in the other
Analytics analytics install that
finally we've got a render function here
that I'm calling and just to note you
don't have to do this inside of regular
python inside of using functions I chose
to do it we reused this app quite a lot
um but if you're more comfortable just
using Jupiter we're pretty deep Jupiter
integration as well so you you don't
necessarily have to use the same method
I've done here but you can see the tabs
that I've created
and then finally I create a video using
data pane which is basically what you
saw on the front page you can see I've
got the image here and then I've got a
very simple four it's not the most
sophisticated app in the world and then
when that form is cooled it just calls
the render function that returns another
components so very basic data payment is
functions all the way down in Python
and again you could be doing this on
your local machine or you could be doing
a host of notebook databricks whatever
it is you're almost comfortable
so here are the libraries that we we
built this app using so we've got dubdb
for the
um for the olap lab we've got Seabourn
for some of the plots we've got Bagel
light Altair and we've taken these open
source libraries put them together and
created this data app which I think goes
pretty far to replacing the external
blender um that we based it upon
so we've built this
um we've built this amp now but is this
realistic or is it still too complicated
so one of the things we found with a lot
of our users is that
um
setting up things like a chrome job or
creating
a lot of the infrastructure around this
even study on WTB can be quite a
challenge if you've never built a data
product before
is it realistic that people are going to
do this but an individual takes
scientist is going to do this or is
there still too much complexity here
and what we thought was missing is an
open source single format for defining
running and deploying data products so
can we take this basic data stack that
we've chosen with all of these different
components from the open source
ecosystem and create a simple format
that allows people to run this as a
package basically inside inside their
company
so we're launching data paint packages
which does basically that so at a high
level it takes all of those moving
pieces and gives you a single python
file that you can then Define all of
those bits in all the way from your
scheduled tasks to your notifications
Integrations email and slack
the olap layer as well if you want to
use duck but it provides a really easy
format for defining this in in one place
and I can actually show you inside of
the
um
app that I built what this looks like
so again I've got a single package here
and that package has a python file it
has a defined what databases I want to
use the scheduled tasks the
notifications and and the workflows so
up to 50 lines of python to do this and
then you get basically a data product
you can run inside of your company and
then on the tasks these are just pretty
simple
um this is actually really CSV in this
case and loading it into dub TV and it's
also creating a daily report so the data
report that gets sent slack or email to
people who need a
so as well as allowing you to Define
this format we also provide the ability
to run it test and deploy it so you can
take this package and
and you can use data paint to actually
run it inside of your company as an
alternative to go into a non-open source
vendor
the tldrms is that you can ship an
end-to-end data product usually in less
than a day
everything's defined in 100 Python and
we'll handle basically the light the
whole app lifecycle on
now I've used a marketing app here
obviously there's a non-constrained
marketing
um we have lots of Open Source apps that
you can that you can check out
everything from HR analytics which I've
got here which provides an open source
version of a common HR analytics product
that you can you can check out and just
as an interactive functions inside of it
as well all the way to more standard
reports
um that you can see the source code for
just check it out in the data pane
website or we've got a booth as well you
can see it on I'll show you some
downloaded and
surround them
if you want to get started
data depends open source so you can just
pip install days pain we also have a
GitHub code spaces or try.dashpane.com
so you can go to that and just be thrown
into juicy notebook where you can build
an app in a couple of minutes
um and you can check us out GitHub the
package of stuff is still in beta so if
you want to demo you want to talk about
that you can come see us at our at our
booth for Early Access and more examples
any questions about anything that I've
I've demo today
hi is there any support for user input
into you know the back end of olap or a
user authentication or would this be
something that you embed into like a
jingle app
yeah it's a very good question and with
to be honest we're still trying to
figure out what levels that should live
so you can because our web server is
wsgi you can't just embed it in
philosophical Django and have basically
um handle it with yourself we're running
some experiments right now especially on
the hlr side levels it's really really
important and things like our back
needed where we expose that as a plug-in
as well so that inside of your app you
can decide
um you know based on the role of the
person doing it whether what access to
what data they should get
um so I think there are there are some
interesting approaches there we'd look
at as well outside of dark using things
like roadbase security as well in the
database to make sure people are getting
the right data
um but yeah there are a couple different
ways to roll Awards and a lot of our
customers are very team United
[Music]
thank you
any other questions
hey hey I'd like to know about
large data sets efficiently so if I have
to put you know a display of the data
frame and then I based up a processing
data frame is the file thing that's got
to be downloaded into that webpage going
to be four different copies of that same
data one for the plugs and one for these
other platforms
thank you yeah so if you if you have
it's a question if you have four
different data sets would we do some
kind of optimization where you don't
have to download all four of them no
it's more like I'm looking at the same
Big Blob of data from four different
views and can I do that efficiently
without downloading four copies oh I see
what you mean yeah you can so we have
the first thing we do offer is caching
so data paint under the hood is a hyper
media format and then these assets that
you're pulling down so in that example
that data set is pulled from our content
layer as an arrow file but that would be
cached if it was being brought down
under some different front-end card
we do have a um a kind of combination
now of either working with data in the
front end so for instance the data table
which I showed you
I think it was in the other app here
this data right now is working in the
front end so if I run this query that's
actually executing everything in memory
of my browser so I wouldn't recommend
using this for a huge data service like
the name Styles so it's okay but for
doing information on that we'd probably
recommend pushing that down to the um
yeah something like Duck DB and running
in on the database
um I'm not quite sure like if I
I've made a map of liver or something
long right and then I added that in how
does that work under the cover because
my data is inside that slide yep sorry I
think I missed some studio question so
in that case you only have the SVG for
MacBook
there so the underlying data set doesn't
have to get reported to the front end
you can think of this more as a kind of
rendering so we take uh say the MacBook
um figure interactive plot a data frame
all of those things they become assets
inside of your uh inside of your app
here if you don't need all the underline
data the in the front end the generator
um I'd recommend pre-aggregating the
data usually before you get it into the
plots so I know that alter generally
puts a limit I think it's like 5
so in that case the constraint would
really be
um how much can the user's browser
plotly itself handle this
um so also we don't provide a
visualization Library so you can use
whichever one you you want
um but we yeah we try and make them work
more efficiently but it's summer details
later on
hey any uh like native authentication
options like Azure active directory and
OCTA or SSO providers out of the box
not yet but it's one of the main things
we're working on
um so we need to absolutely kind of
similar to the conversation we had
earlier uh I think SSO
and the bar back is going to be a really
important thing for us and we're working
with some of it's mainly on the HR side
that we're working with these customers
to do that and we're trying to design
what the right API would look like um
thanks
great any other questions
no
it's fantastic well thank you so much
for um yeah let me show you what we're
doing in a data pane we have a booth
around the corner as I mentioned that
you can come and check out if you want
to see any demos if you want to see the
examples and case studies we've got a
boatload of different data products that
we've created that you can try out as
well so yeah kind of say hi and thanks
so much
[Applause]